I've always been interested to see what
I would look like with long hair this is
about as long as I've ever had my hair I
look forward to doing a lot of this and
a lot of that you want a headband got
long hair that's like the whole reason
if I liked the long hair I'm definitely
growing my hair out
what Wow well what I'm like a very
feminine khal drogo I think I got them
on the cover of like some stupid romance
novel like hey I bet you so much money
people gonna walk by and be like Jesus I
look like a very disappointing geisha I
just feel like I'll put on that voice
the whole times but hey there's the
organic produce so I feel like where
this every time I go out let the week
begin Ricky just did my hair you look
50% pretty and 50% dangerous I don't
even know what to say
Jesus I can told you Jesus
it's a beautiful sunny day and I'm going
for a stroll just drive more chill I
think it makes me worse right I don't
like how the hair tickles my face I can
parallel park along here no problem so
my hair is stuck to my headphones like
Marvin I today a new man good bike Kid
Rock well I'm walking the streets of
Hollywood with my gorgeous light hair
and no one's batting an eye which is
nice so I feel pretty self-conscious
yeah I look like Jesus I'm starting to
look like a wild cave woman and this
rain isn't really helping I just feel
like a fraud you know like maybe just a
leg
maybe it's the length of the hair so I'm
about to head to the gym now and today's
been a bit of a pain because my hair
just keeps getting in the way almost
like something's always tickling my face
I'm saying why killing I like I just
took like three excedrin migraine right
now it's hot the hairs in my face and
stuff the aesthetic is all wrong for me
I think I enjoyed it a lot more than I
thought I would
I felt greasy ER and dirtier it only
looks cool like in a few instances I
can't just leave I have to like put it
on like put the bald cap on and like put
the pins and I was telling that to one
of my friends and she was like oh well
that's what it's like to be a woman and
have long hair struggle is real when I
first had the wig I felt very
self-conscious but really people don't
care I felt like people were looking at
me differently
my girlfriend liked it my girlfriend
hated it because it's so real-looking it
was kind of confusing for her I think
she thought it would be really sexy and
I came home and she was very embarrassed
a lot of people were telling me that I
was acting differently I was walking
with more of a swagger so I could feel
my hair in the wind I think now that
I've seen myself long hair I don't need
to see it again it's not me I am totally
gonna grow my hair out I'm totally into
it